[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Teşekkürler
yıllar
ne zaman
Y
ikisinde de eksiklik var
ve buradan
bu yağ
1 şehir listesi
ürün
ince ile
motor olma gerçeği olabilir
Y
yada daha fazla
alan nedir
sadece arka planda
ve şili ile iyi görünse de biz
Peki
gonzalez
şişman kadın
ve uzun süre hatırla
Evet
şehir
mercanlar
nereye gidiyoruz
ve bu kadar
özgürlük biçimleri
ve organize ettim
Evet
ve
eksiğimiz için
Epeyce
m
Ey
artı
şimdi ülkeyi genişlet
güneş havuzu grubu
seviye 8
Bu şehirde
Evet
saymak
Evet öyleyim
Ey
ben
sonrasında
sonra
bir
s
nereden geliyor
genç exxon
bu zaman
m
Evet
Ben
bir
daha sonra doldurmam gerekiyor
ve bununla
Bence
ne kadar yıkıcı
fazla
içinde
sorun
Bence o konuşmacı ama bana her şeyi verdi
ve şimdilik
yani benim için evet
tüm sağ ve aitor ile
Bence
favori
D
adalet
test çok adil
Ey
Y
ana
[Müzik]
veya daha fazla 1
bir pelerinle bir gülümsemeyle
çoğu doğruyu söylüyor
hareket edecekler
Böyle
konu hakkında
bir
as
[Alkış]
Ancak
Ey
Diyor
kantonlar
bir
Y
uzayı modelleyeceğimiz zaman
Hayır
ve bu kadar
erkeklerle başla
bu çünkü burada
daha sonra
veya sebep olarak
Y
buluştuğumuzda
20 aya ulaşmak
fazla
çünkü ikiden biri isterse
Y
hepimiz konuşacağız
Tanrı
Allah
kontrol edilecek eşyalarım
siparişe göre bask
onun ile
hap mesajında
ve sana kolay yardım
Y
[Alkış]
Ey
bunun sayesinde birbirimizi seviyoruz
herkes
Ey
bunun hakkında da konuşabilirsin
gördüğün tüm gruba sahip olduklarında
hakkında
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
görünüş için
[Alkış]
Ey
benim
Y
[Alkış]
aktör gibi